a new Paper Mario game has entered the
fold Evo online details have been
released and Epic Games is making cross
play that much easier i'm persia and
you've reached your save date for
Thursday May 14 Nintendo helped us start
our day right with a surprise trailer
for a new Paper Mario game for switch
Paper Mario the origami King has as
you'd expect a new origami element King
alley is out to fold the world and we
all know who'll be the one to stop him
the trailer shows Mario teaming up with
unlikely allies and a new ring based
battle system that mixes puzzle solving
skills with traditional turn-based
combat when Mario and Bowser a team of
you know it's about to get real Paper
Mario the origami King has a release
date set for July 17th and makes me
wonder what other Mario games we could
see come to switch Yoshi's Island anyone
due to the pandemic Evo has officially
introduced Evo online except for smash
exhibitions and content are planned for
the original games that were on the
roster but for new games were added to
the lineup for open online tournaments
over the course of five weekends we'll
see exhibitions from under name birth
Dragonball Fighters Tekken 7 Street
Fighter 5 soul calibur 6 Grambling
Fantasy Versus and Samurai Shodown
what's more interesting is the addition
of four games strictly for open online
tournaments those games are Mortal
Kombat 11 killer instinct men's fight in
herds and coal girls I'm dusting off my
peacock in big band to enter some skull
girls but are you guys entering any of
the four new editions if so let me know
because I'm trying to run some sense Evo
is one of many in the gaming industry
that are being affected by the crisis
but for those of you worried Phil
Spencer sends us a bit of optimism
Spencer told Business Insider that Xbox
won't experience any major delays this
year as a result of the changing work
environment and the series X will still
be launching this holiday season slight
delays could happen to projects set for
launch in 2021 as major tasks like
motion capture cannot be performed from
home through the summer to early fall I
felt pretty good about those games
Spencer said games that we're targeting
a year from now are beyond there will be
some impact
but they'll be able to react spencer
signed off with a silver lining by
reminding us that a lot of games are in
production across the industry right now
and as an industry we're gonna be sign
with that said epic is making it easier
for developers to allow cross play to
all platforms with some free new tools
you can play for at night just about
anywhere and epic online services is
getting all the cross play tools
necessary for any developer to do the
same and add PC Mac Xbox one and switch
support to their game free of charge
Android and iOS support is planned for a
later date and could lead to more cross
play experiences in the future the free
stuff doesn't stop there for epic as
this week's free epic game store title
is Grand Theft Auto 5 you might get hit
with some errors as you're trying to
claim it but don't stress too much
because it's available for a week that's
our news for the day but if you're
looking for the juice on ghost of
Tsushima well game spots got you covered
there too we've got all the details up
on our channel now and on gamespot.com
so go check it out you guys can follow
me on twitter at persia underscore XO
and we'll see you next time